[Music]
welcome back to curious archive this
video is a new chapter in my
long-running series exploring the
incredible speculative evolution project
of serena the world of birds
sereno was created by dylan betta a
terrific artist and world builder and
many exciting developments have occurred
since we last explored his creation you
may remember the fascinating premise of
the serena project an unknown force
leaves a colony of finches on the moon
of serena along with a few other plant
and animal species to serve as their
food supply the project imagines the
amazing life forms that evolve from
these humble beginnings over millions of
years creatures that i've explored in
past videos
for this entry into the archive we'll
chronicle the next era in this
evolutionary epic and witness the rise
and fall of countless species as the
world of serena continues to change
so let's return to this strange moon and
remember to support dylan betta on
patreon using the links below if you're
a fan of this project
when we left off the moon of serena was
home to a teeming menagerie of
incredible life forms
yet as the middle ultimacine period
wears on the planet has continued to
cool and in this changing environment
many species are now threatened
somewhere on the step on a cold night
the last of the flying giants looms tall
above the grasses for 10 million years
their species the storm sonars ruled the
skies as the largest flying lifeforms
ever to exist now without enough warm
land to reproduce this storm sonar will
be the last of their kind the loss of
the storm sonars is emblematic of how
more specialized species won't survive
this changing world
and thus far on serena no species has
had a story like the woodcrafters and
the gravediggers for centuries these two
life forms were enemies predator and
prey divided by a seemingly
insurmountable gap yet now these two
species live together in peace and
remain in harmony for the next several
millennia in the words of the author the
triumphs and tragedies the joys and the
sadness of ten thousand years worth of
lifetimes could fill their own story but
upon serena where chapters are more
often measured in tens of millions of
years their time together is just a
dog-eared page in the book of life
and this chapter two must come to a
close for the woodcrafters eventually go
extinct always a small population with a
highly specialized diet as temperatures
change they find that the broadleaf
forests they depend on disappear and
soon only one woodcrafter remains
on nights where the skies are clear the
elderly last woodcrafter stands on the
shore of the ocean and looks out at the
horizon
most nights her small companion a
chattering sparrow gold simply called
bird joins her as a chatterer bird
possesses the ability to mimic the
woodcrafter's language even if they
can't grasp the full meaning of the
words yet on nights like this when the
last woodcrafter repeats the phrase i
love you bird to their dear friend bird
understands that they are cared for
after a long life the elderly last
woodcrafter comes to rest surrounded by
her gravedigger family in her lifetime
she's seen the gravediggers achieve
things she never knew were possible
harnessing blazing lights in their hands
and shaping tools unlike anything her
kind had made what's more the
gravediggers have begun to weave grasses
into floating structures upon which they
ride out into the sea for days at a time
the last woodcrafter knows the
gravediggers will continue to change the
world and urges them to explore what
lies beyond the horizon
and just before the last woodcrafter
closes her eyes she sees glimpses of a
cosmic story she can't understand images
of a small bird a little fish moments
long before her time and moments yet to
occur
and through it all the last woodcrafter
feels a strange presence who tells her
she's done well
and then the page turns to another
chapter and the last woodcrafter is no
more
her gravedigger family lay her to rest
on the hill overlooking the sunset she
so enjoyed in an act that brings the
saga of two species to a close this is
the very last time the gravediggers
shall dig a pit for a woodcrafter her
companion bird lands upon her antler for
some time not understanding why their
friend is silent
bird stays in the gravedigger village
for a few days watching them cast out to
sea the gravediggers are determined to
fulfill the final wishes of the
woodcrafter and chart what lies beyond
the horizon the last woodcrafter told
them that in a world as big as this one
there had to be more intelligent species
like themselves somewhere out upon the
sea they hope to fulfill the dream of
their dear friend
and bird flies off on their own beyond
the beach they know so well but they
never forget the last woodcrafter or the
phrase i love you bird which they repeat
to their children who like bird do not
understand the meaning but understand
the context in which to use these words
for the chatterers are in fact the
descendants of the last babbling jays
the first advanced intelligent life to
emerge for a brief time on serena all
those eons ago and while chatterers
aren't as intelligent as their ancestors
from the pangea scene they are a species
to keep an eye on through the coming
generations the last woodcrafter lives
on in the words the wild shatterers
affectionately whisper to each other
carrying her memory across the stretch
of time
and out to sea the gravediggers have
found a new brighter era has begun the
ocean age as serena has continued to
cool the majority of the plant and
animal life have become reliant upon an
equatorial ocean between the massive ice
sheets of the north and south while the
sea level has technically dropped in
this period the oceans rise to greater
importance than ever before in serena's
history while braving these waters the
gravediggers will have to contend with
all manner of life
swimming near the surface are the
gigantic oceanic pike birds while they
look like fish as their name implies
pikebirds are in fact birds specifically
metamorph birds a clade which have
managed to conquer all manners of niches
across serena thanks to their highly
variable biology
pike birds evolve from tadpole like
larvae over millions of years with the
laws of hydrodynamics and convergent
evolution shaping them into remarkably
fish-like organisms and as long as food
remains abundant these fish birds will
likely continue to flourish
but the seas of the early ocean age
aren't just populated by aquatic birds
the sea dragon is a descendant of fish
like the swordtail and is a highly
successful species albeit the last of
their particular group able to breathe
atmospheric air for a short period the
sea dragon has converged on a niche not
dissimilar from earth crocodiles
and anyone familiar with earth's natural
history knows that the crocodile niche
is a pretty enviable long-term gig so to
speak as crocodiles have stuck around
since the age of the dinosaurs and at 15
feet or four and a half meters the sea
dragons are massive predators but
they're far from the largest things
patrolling these oceans
elsewhere upon the waves a huge horde of
gnashing teeth and shifting legs moves
upon the surface
this is a sea shoggoth and it's a colony
of the most unexpected creature the ant
left on cerenai as a food source
millions of years ago the unassuming
ants have quietly been evolving in the
margins since the beginning of this epic
by the early ultimacine certain ant
colonies had adapted to move in super
colonies millions strong devouring
everything too slow to escape their
advance through the underbrush
and now in the ocean age the descendants
of these ravenous colonies have taken to
the sea functioning like a single
massive predator with many see shoghoths
more than 30 feet or 9 meters across
they require a tremendous amount of food
to function once a humble food source
these ants are now the hunters other
species need to watch their backs
but the social gravediggers are thriving
just 5 000 years after the last
woodcrafter they've become a skilled
seafaring civilization with traps tools
in a written language metalworking
however is difficult in such an
environment and has never been
discovered so their technological growth
has remained largely unchanged for many
centuries yet in all that time the
gravediggers haven't forgotten the last
woodcrafter's message from oral
traditions and art like this tablet the
memory of their lost friends has been
kept alive
the gravediggers have immortalized the
woodcrafters as parent-like figures who
help show them the value of life
different from themselves as a result
modern gravedigger culture emphasizes
the gravediggers are only a small part
of a wider food web and that somewhere
in the ocean there must be other
intelligent life forms
little do they know that deep below the
water surface another intelligence has
indeed developed in the form of the
daydreamers these lifeforms have been
evolving unnoticed under the wave since
before the rise of the woodcrafters and
in that time the daydreamers developed a
way of thinking which is entirely unique
we've actually met the ancestor of the
daydreamers before in the saga in the
form of the sea strikers a group of
predators with intelligence roughly
analogous to a dolphins the sea strikers
learned to farm and feed upon the
porplets a type of dolphinch that were
also quite intelligent and in the modern
day the daydreamers have evolved a truly
distinctive form of intelligence their
brain is divided into two hemispheres
that can function independently of each
other so that one half can sleep while
the other remains active strange as this
might sound the brain hemispheres of
certain dolphins can also do this to a
lesser extent but the experience of
having a brain like a daydreamer would
be strange indeed because the daydreamer
dreams while wide awake taking these
dreams as visions and prophecies the
daydreamers are a highly spiritual
populace and there is one legend that
stands out from the others a creation
myth glimpse through shifting dreams of
how serena came to be
according to the daydreamers in the
beginning a mysterious creator was alone
in the void to amuse themselves they
began to build forming something from
the nothing until the world itself was
drawn into creation the creator forged
the air the water in the land and all of
the life that dwelled upon the three
realms then the creator gazed down from
above and grew curious
the creator wished to experience the new
world not from the outside but from
within
and so the creator fractured their
essence into thirds one soared off into
the limitless sky the necks walked upon
the shores and far beyond and there they
continued to reshape and change the land
as they saw fit the last settled in the
lowest realm using their strong flippers
to dive down deep into the seas in the
daydreamers believe that one day the
three splinters will find one another
again and the creator will finish its
journey it's a fascinating tale and
perhaps some form of truth lies hidden
in the daydreamer's mythos in any case
while the story is one of unity a
dangerous societal rift currently exists
between two distinct daydreamer
populations
the undersea daydreamer populations are
divided between a group called the
fishers in a group called the
pastoralists
the fishers feed entirely on small
aquatic life and have a close alliance
with the intelligent luddies a relative
of the porplets they once farmed the
fishers are a uniquely social and
curious group and have taken on an
almost parental role in keeping the
bloodies safe from predators
in contrast the pastoralists live a very
different lifestyle they continue the
ancient survival strategy of farming
porplets for food which is reflected in
their larger serrated beaks the porplets
however are much changed becoming the
knop a livestock species almost too
rotund to swim and blissfully unable to
comprehend their situation indeed the
knob can only survive thanks to the
protection of their pastoralist
farmhands
this complicated situation however has
led to a seemingly endless cold war
between the two populations with the
fishers seeing the pastoralists as evil
in the pastoralists seeing the fishers
as bizarre extremists yet now an ancient
threat is emerging that threatens both
populations for there is another long
lost faction of daydreamers these are
the warmongers a huge offshoot that
evolved to hunt wild prey in the distant
open oceans they diverged even before
the fishers and the pastoralists split
off and now this isolationist subset has
found their cousins again and the
warmongers have their own beliefs that
they alone are the sole descendants of a
dead god and therefore are above all
other life including the daydreamers the
jaws of the warmongers don't distinguish
between fishers and pastoralists and now
an all-out war is beginning
but the other day dreamers have hope
hope because the fishers believe that
they have found another aspect of the
creator from their most sacred myth for
some time now the ever curious fishers
have been aware of the gravediggers
finding their tools upon the ocean floor
strange relics from another realm many
fishers come to wonder if perhaps these
strange creatures are one of the lost
essences of their supposed creators
and with the warmonger threat on the
rise the fishers have decided to at last
make contact with the strange creatures
from the surface the first gravediggers
to be greeted by a talking whale
urgently pleading for their help were
surely confused and indeed the first
fishers able to mimic the gravedigger's
slow guttural language are in perfect
messengers at best but the gravediggers
are eager to listen
news of talking whales travels quickly
as it is the fulfillment of the
gravedigger's own mythos just as it is
the fishers to meet another intelligent
species and as communication improves
and the danger of the warmongers becomes
clear the gravediggers realize it will
take both the fishers and the
pastoralists united to stop them and
while neither side believes an alliance
is possible for once they have a common
ally and a common enemy but the
warmongers have been watching a select
few know the daydreamers have allied
with mysterious animals from above the
water and see the gravediggers as a
threat to warmogger culture after all
the advanced gravediggers seem like
living proof the daydreamer creation
story has more truth than they assumed
with their size and strength what chance
would the puny gravediggers have against
them but indeed by dragging the
gravediggers into the war the warmongers
make a fatal mistake in their next
battle with the daydreamers fishers and
pastoralists strike with poison spears
that the warmongers can't comprehend and
wear stark white plates and bones that
block the force of their jaws with armor
and weapons created by the gravediggers
the daydreamers are now more than a
match for the warmonger legions
but the warmongers aren't as homogeneous
as they first appear they too are made
of different groups forged from
generations of struggle and many are
only seeking to survive
and as the tides of war change young
warmongers questioned their allegiance
to their leader after much suffering the
old figures of power are violently cast
out and the warmonger ranks are
shattered from within in the war for the
ocean at last comes to an end
healing and reconciliation do not come
immediately for such things are rarely
so simple the immediate fighting has
ceased yet the warmonger remnants are
now leaderless and disrupted and the
fishers and pastoralists remain divided
yet as the years become centuries and
centuries become millennia daydreamers
begin to blend guided in part by their
allies from the land together this
coastal alliance of gravediggers and
daydreamers will persist over a time
scale no culture before them has ever
come close to
and the gravediggers would never forget
their oldest allies the woodcrafters who
help make all of this possible
there are many stories yet to be told
and questions yet to be answered but
that's all i can give away for now
the story of serena is still ongoing and
if you find the project as thought
provoking as i do please support dylan
betta on patreon to gain access to
entries further along in serena's future
i've got links in the description and as
always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video
you